sur rt france benoît me rationne il est
président de l' ong action sécurité
éthiques et républicaines
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en sur rt
france en direct tout d'abord une
première réaction après cette annonce du
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu
bonjour c'est un scandale un terrible
scandale
cela montre que là les états sont
achetés comme les clubs de football en
angleterre par l'arabie saoudite ou les
emirats arabes unis on s'y tient à vis
il dit mais il ya aussi les émirats
arabes unis qui sont aussi très impliqué
dans cette histoire le but de ces deux
pays notamment avec tous les autres pays
de la ville et de la coalition c'est de
faire oublier les crimes de guerre et
les crimes contre l'humanité au yémen et
ils y sont parvenus dans une situation
qui est absolument pas ce que le groupe
d'experts des nations unies tel groupe
d'experts extrêmement léger quant à
comparer par exemple au groupe d'experts
sur les crimes commis en syrie c'était à
l'époque une de communistes et un groupe
d'experts une enquête internationale et
indépendante
or jamais ce groupe d'experts au yémen
n'a eu ce mandat là cette capacité
juridique d'enquêter sur les graves
crimes commis des droits nationaux des
droits de l'homme et du droit
international humanitaire alors
maintenant on a parlé du côté un
politique un on va parler du côté
humanitaire
telle ampleur on peut avoir cette
décision sur les conditions humaines
dairy milk
est ce que nous montrons dans notre
rapport que nous avons sorti l'année
dernière ont dès le 10 décembre date du
diverses déclarations de
l'universel la déclaration des droits de
l'homme
et bien ce que l'on montre c'est que les
bombardements systématiques continues
sur dans des zones civiles également
ciblant les hôpitaux ciblant les moyens
de subsistance des yéménites c'est à
dire par exemple est chiant
les pêcheurs pour les empêcher d'aller
d'honorer la population les stations
d'eau etc c'est un rapport que vous
pouvez trouver sur le site désert azer
tirer à ce point org et et bien les il
n'y aura plus aucune représentation
indépendante qui pourra enquêter sur ces
actions de la part de la coalition
dirigée par l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis alors que chaque
année
les
instances des nations unies nous informe
que la situation humanitaire s'aggrave
au quotidien on avait il y avait une
estimation de plus de 230 mille morts de
mort directe et indirecte au conflit fin
2019 avec la crise du code vide on ne
sait pas où on en est c'est déjà très
difficile de pouvoir évaluer mais alors
là ce sera carrément impossible alors
l'envoyé spécial ans de règne pour le
yémen en seconde berg ap un règlement
global ans à règlement comme on en perd
bien et finalement tu ya une véritable
marge de manoeuvre pourrait mener ce
conflit
alors on se signent ce vote est le est
la preuve que la marge de manoeuvre est
extrêmement fine
puisque le vote s'était 21 contre le
renouvellement de cette commission c'est
ce groupe d'experts des nations unies et
il y avait 19 pour il ya une situation
extrêmement hypocrite dans les pays
occidentaux dont la france a voté oui
mais dans le même temps la france a voté
oui et elle
elle continue d'armer l'arabie saoudite
les émirats arabes unis tous les autres
pays de la coalition en violation de
l'article 6 du traité sur le commerce
des armes c'est dire pour cela cazères
est toujours devant le conseil d'état
pour demander la suspension de ces de
ces transferts donc comment comment
réagir et comment faire en sorte que ce
combat puisse cesser est-ce que les
révélations se font de part et d'autre
y'a pas un groupe armé pour sauver un
pour en sauver un autre et bien c'est en
arrêtant le flux des armes
quand on a pour se battre il faut des
armes il faut des munitions dans
l'émission qui fait partie bien sûr des
sommes est
c'est ce que nous demandons auprès de
gouvernement français c'est ce que
l'allemagne a décidé même s'il faut
qu'elle le fasse respecter par les
entreprises allemandes puisque la rai
métal notamment continue d'exporter par
l'afrique du sud il faut que l'italie le
fasse la décla ré il faut qu'il fasse
complètement les états unis ou s'ils ont
déclaré qu'ils allaient
arrêter leurs exportations d'armes au
liban les émirats arabes unis de
l'arabie saoudite il faut qu'elle fasse
complètement la grande bretagne la même
chose la belgique enfin il ya tous les
pays occidentaux qui ont pu voter et qui
ont voté le renouvellement de ce groupe
d'experts d'éminents experts
alimentent largement cette guerre donc
on a un discours absolument hypocrite de
l'art par un on a une position
officielle qui dirait oui bien sûr qu'il
faut le renouvellement de ce go et d'un
autre côté de l'autre côté et bien ils
continuent de soutenir les pays qui sont
responsables de ces graves violations de
30 ha sionisme a été un héros de l'homme
et il y aura un moment donné nous
l'espérons les peuples qui demanderont
des comptes quant à la complicité des
gouvernements comme celui comme le
gouvernement français et il y à un autre
position qui est extrêmement pur
monotype qui est la position de la
russie et de la chine dont on attendait
beaucoup plus et qui ont eux aussi voté
contre le renouvellement de ce groupe
d'éminents experts benoît mur ascione
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président
d'orange réaction sécurité éthique
républicaine mercier vous aussi